blanca lopez comes to this fair three
times a week to sell some of her clothes
to get cash
she lost her job during the pandemic and
comes here with her disabled daughter
because it is the only chance she has to
make a living
i was working cleaning houses and during
the pandemic i lost my job my daughter
is receiving some government assistance
and with that and the old clothes i sell
we try to survive
people in argentina are struggling with
one of the highest inflation rates in
the world about six percent a month many
who come here lost their jobs in the
past years
people come here to sell some food and
clothes among other things but also to
participate in a lottery where they come
and they put some food in this bag that
you can see here some pasta lentils and
then
they write their names in this little
bag
the name that comes out is the winner
and that person takes all this food back
home
but food is not the only thing that's
being raffled
o carlo yarate sells tickets for a few
cents each the money he collects is also
offered as a lottery price
he says increasing numbers of people are
coming here to try to win extra money
[Music]
people are coming here because of the
economic situation people tell us they
cannot find a job and this is what they
have we are adding extra days so they
can come sell something this is the only
way they have to get by on a day-to-day
basis the biggest price is around three
dollars the second is two dollars and
the third just won
it's a lottery for the poor
who now account for more than forty
percent of argentina's population
rossio lisaraga was happy with the money
she won
even though it will only last for a day
everyone is struggling my husband has a
job my mom cleans houses and they give
their old clothes and i bring those
clothes here i have a four-year-old
daughter so i cannot work because i
can't afford daycare
argentina's government spends millions
on projects to assist the poor
but people like eduardo donsa say it's
not enough
with an inflation rate of around five or
six percent most of the cash transfers
made by the state lose value argentina
has a strong state presence around 30 of
the population already receives
assistance aside from the pensions
argentina is trying to jump start the
economy and generate quality jobs
but it has not been easy
fairs like this one have become a
crucial lifeline for many in times of
economic distress
perishable al jazeera buenos aires